let's see says we're gonna live says
we're gonna live and we're live so hello
everybody and welcome to round table
with the stream team and this is where
we come to talk to amazing content
creators that we have met you know their
journeys of where they started and where
they are today today we have with us a
very good streamer friend of mine who
I've known for what is it two or three
years now
it's it's Ted's denty how are you
tonight what's going on brother
doing well doing well so we're gonna
we're gonna talk to him about some
amazing things he'd be doing what he's
doing up to where his where he began and
everything and we have tonight with us
we have l-boogie Oh - oh wait how are
you hey how you doing I'm doing well I'm
happy to say everyone's back for more
almost a month hiatus it felt like I
felt like four it was three weeks in
December and then it was it was in
December and then last week and then
this week so it's been it's been almost
four weeks so happy to see you happy to
see your back and and our buddy
MJ MJ is a boss yo what's up how are you
you're very quiet and you know you
didn't use your catchphrase what what's
poppin that is your catchphrase oh
please don't be addict on me here get
some adrenaline get some kind of Red
Bull and you know it's it's if it makes
you feel a better snellie I've got a
monster in my hand so I got my alright I
have my tea here laced with some black
cooking yeah let tar heroin yeah yeah
yeah my black tar bourbon so which is my
black tea for the evening so um well
what let's let's start this up let us up
its identity why did you decide
originally that you wanted to become a
content creator that you wanted to start
streaming on Twitch
and going through those paths go through
a down a path okay well you want like a
short and sweet answer you want like a
long and detailed answer ah you can you
can do whichever you want I mean we got
time so if you want to do the long
detailed or if you want to synopsis
importance of it well the short and
sweet is like I've been gaming I got a
Nintendo like when I was 3 was a
hand-me-down and I've had been playing
games ever since I was three years old
literally so whenever I wasn't I mean I
was one of those kids that was just like
oh hey you should be doing your homework
no I'm gaming like every game that came
out every new game I needed it and I
just been gaming forever super
passionate about gaming only thing I
really cared about was over gaming and I
worked really hard all the time
so I could just always have the new
system every console every the new PC
new PC game new PC parts I always worked
so I could do that the long and the
longer answer would be my passion for
video games I grew up being told I
couldn't make money playing video games
or even creating video games and it was
just like that lack of information and
that's like not the world that we live
in now and honestly in regards to how I
got started on Twitch what it meant to
be if I'm being completely transparent
I did not good obviously you could say
however which way you want you can do
whatever you want as long as you're not
like streaming a million curse words
together so did you put other than that
you're totally fine I tried my [ __ ]
best
um no I'm sorry the the long the the
longer answer so continue in regards to
choosing to which at the time when I
wanted a stream to which was the only
platform that really had a competitive
edge had any edge was getting traction
and what it meant to be a quote unquote
content creator what it means today they
would Pete how people use that word and
when I was interested in doing it it's
not the same thing the people I was
watching was Co carnage people I was
watching was summit camp Kay goth you
know pink Italian rather you know
Towelie playing World of Warcraft like
those guys weren't making YouTube videos
they weren't
on Instagram they weren't Tim that I was
watching Tim he wasn't on YouTube making
a video every day with an editor blah
blah blah
they were streaming and they were
engaging with their community and that's
just not the name of the game anymore
like if you are doing just that you are
sitting on twitch wasting your time and
so the content creator I've actually
like learned this through I got
partnered doing what I wanted to do
which was stream and engage and I had
like an unbelievable following playing
the division which is where I met you
and then the game this the script
flipped and the game changed and what it
meant to be a successful streamer
changed and I don't have the skill set
to I didn't have the skill set been
teaching myself master classes all this
other stuff I've got the whole Adobe
Photoshop premier suite and was like now
it's like oh hey I just switch if I
still want to do this I need to become a
content creator and not just a streamer
who is engaging with the community that
they're trying to build so now so you
pretty much what you're saying is like
we knew when you started it was just
straight engagement with the community
and that's how that's how that's how I
started I mean that's that's what I it
was just engaging with the community
talking to the people doing your thing I
didn't have time to learn it and and but
now it's it's like you have to diversify
everything you have to be the master of
six different hats and you have to be
able to push yourself forward or you
have to be making enough money to have
other people be doing that for you right
no no I was just I was just gonna answer
your original question but you're
absolutely right
I wanted to I'm passionate about video
games no matter what I'm doing I always
go back to video games I have a
background I saw I went to school got a
degree in computer science I've worked
in a bunch of different tech jobs I hate
sitting at a cube which is funny that I
actually don't mind sitting in my desk
all day but it's different I just don't
like sitting and not talking to people
and then I went into sales turns out
that I [ __ ] live for
cut working for my pay working for you
no Commission I love that so I worked as
a consultant for a number of years but
in my free time all I did was watch
streamers I would watch Co carnage I've
got like thousands of hours of over the
years of watching Co carnage Tim the tap
man summit you know those guys like come
up I even watched ninja when ninja was
like young and she had talking all the
time I loved that ninja I used to watch
doctor disrespect when he first started
and then he stops because it became a
developer and then he came back and I
remember when he had like 300 people of
this channel like now it's like you know
3 million in the arena it's just like
that bad vibe doesn't exist anymore but
it's still there it's just a different
name in the game I'm still passionate
about it I love like the idea of being a
streamer but the content creator
question I still ask myself like am I
really a content creator or my streamer
because I feel like what it used to mean
to me is not the same thing but now it
has to what I feel but look what I felt
that content creator now it encapsulates
the word streamer because I mean I think
that a lot of people now and prime
example is last week and I knew this I
had a feeling I was my brain in the back
of my head I was gonna bring this up
those guys from escape from tarkov them
doing the Twitter ops for their game
they ended up making that whole entire
community blow up it like it went from
people because I've been streaming
escape from tarkov since October flash
of last year and there was only like 10
to 15,000 people watching and then it
was boomed up to 250 to 280 thousand
people watching all because people
wanted that and that was pure publicity
that they wanted and the guys from BAU
say games ended up hands picking a bunch
of individuals to be allowed to
participate in those twists drops and if
you let those we're always the biggest
streamers
so it was very smart for them for
marketing to allow that to happen and
that's why I think that it's turned into
more of another way to market people's
games and I mean that's it's just what's
gonna end up happening and because
streamers are now cons and creators and
marketers and all these other channels
just not just streamers which is what
what I which I think was a great way to
do it if you wanted to see someone
playing Warcraft or division or or any
of those games there fortnight you could
just go watch them but now you have to
produce these videos or they won't have
those consistent views anymore anymore
because people forget about them well I
mean that was always a thing with sure
first of all let me say this I agree
with pretty much everything that you
were saying it's not the first time
something like this has happened I'm not
sure if you're familiar with warframe
we're frame has an identical track
record with escape from tarkov
and while I personally enjoy safer and
tarkov because I have loved games like
survival survival in the divisions what
got me partnered this is right up my
alley
I'm I know that even you know I started
playing it today again but I know for a
fact that this and you know those that
10,000 number that you were talking
about it will be that number again just
shoot and this is a hype train and it's
a hike wave and people are gonna ride it
and they like I'm watching I'm looking
at the directory right now so I'm it's
sitting at the top of it right you know
and then Presley who was sitting with a
hundred thousand viewers is sitting with
10k and this is like the roller-coaster
ride now the people in this directory
who stay relevant it will be the ones
who create content on the biggest search
engines that being YouTube and being
easily accessible on Google so the
people who create content the people who
can keep their momentum moving will be
the people who are successful and
regardless of what game they play but
it's interesting that it's interesting
to hear your perception of it because so
I've been in
the where you're aware that I've been
under like a lot of NDA's for different
games and a lot with the division with
Ubisoft in general and they've been very
kind to me and it's just interesting to
see the front side of like people's
perception and then people like what's
actually happening behind the scenes and
like how much money is moving around in
you're not wrong at all but there's just
so much more money being like serda
round and a lot of it's interesting
where you're like oh the biggest
streamers get things it's really not
even so much about that you'd be
surprised how much of it is just so you
know you're friends with um well like
like L like she I mean you can you can
chime in on that's like you know a lot
of people before for Microsoft like for
the Xbox community correct you know a
few people just you're not gonna not
gonna drop any names and pick them up
off the grounds or anything like that
you can like you've seen that insight
behind behind the before it's it's
different yeah so it's it's kind of
interesting that they you know hearing
it from other people's perspectives that
have seen the other side and to hear it
from people's perspectives that don't
know so it's kind of it's kind of
interesting to see how that kind of like
um it flip flops back and forth but we
can literally sit here and talk about
stuff like that all day but I what I
really want to talk about is denty so
I'm gonna I'm gonna kind of pull back
the reins a little bit
before sharing we before we end up doing
a tangent that could probably talk for
for a couple of hours um when you when
you started streaming but we're like the
challenges that you ended up facing when
you when you started it's actually being
physically inactive so like playing so
here's the perception right it's like
it's not your jobs not hard you're just
playing video games like don't [ __ ]
complain about anything you punk and
it's like yeah you're right I play video
games but like
sitting for hours constantly talking for
hours non-stop like being on knowing
that someone's watching you and like
everything that you're doing has a light
is changing someone's perception of you
and your perception is people's
perception of you is everything and
really being on it's like one thing when
you're youtuber and all you have to do a
smile in these frames and you can you
can cut that you know 50 times you
cussed and the 50 times you messed up
out but like sitting there and having to
be on the whole time when I first
started streaming I could not read chat
and be good at the game at the same time
or I was either a good witch at well
yeah a cup it's like a muscle it's like
riding a bike you eventually build it
and it becomes a callus and then you're
just it's just there and so sometimes I
will I will see chat in my peripheral
vision I have three monitors I can
always see you I'm ignoring you because
I don't want to suck and so like there
are some chats you go to and they're
like oh I'm not talking to my chat
because that's not the kind of content
I'm creating I didn't start my channel
because I didn't want to not talk to
people I do want to talk to people if
anything I want them to like give me an
opportunity to get on the mic with me so
I can make them laugh and you know talk
as much [ __ ] as humanly possible as like
bro friendly good knocking but like I
sometimes people don't want they don't
want you talking and laughing they want
to see you not suck at a game they want
to show you they want to watch you be
better than them they want to see you be
that NBA player who's Duncan when they
can dunk or that NASCAR driver who's
driving at speeds they can't drive or
just that shroud who's aiming the way
they can't aim or that tee foo who's
Eating the way they can't eat like you
know I mean like it just they want to
see that so do you feel like I be king
I'm sorry no I was just gonna say in
survival I took the world record for
survival wins and it was just hard
grinding but I couldn't talk I couldn't
talk at the same time I couldn't pay
attention everyone
right so it was hard because you always
you're always asking yourself like
what's important what are your what kind
of channel are you building and I
modeled my original channel after Coe
carnage because I his his motto is happy
helpful friendly and while I might not
necessarily be the friendliest person
because if you talk [ __ ] to me I'm gonna
let you
but I I definitely wanted to be helpful
and I definitely wanted to like kind of
educate people while still having fun
right so you you had to pick that
balance you would because I like we were
saying before I've known you for a while
we've gained before together we played
Division two together we played Division
one together we've played a bunch of
different games together ends like you
you play this fine line of either you
want to be the best of the best
hence all your your fortnight at times
that you've gone through and I've seen
you do some crazy stuff in there that
there's no way that I can perform and
then you can either go in that direction
or like the family-friendly direction
and I know that that's you you kind of
have to you have been skirting that I
mean I I've tried so I stopped cussing
when I played for tonight I would think
I would try to think in my head it's
like alright what wouldn't I say
standing outside of her church you know
what I mean like if I said like what I
feel about it standing I'm not saying
what I wouldn't say in a church but if I
was standing outside of what would I be
like what did I just say and I you know
or what I wouldn't say like at work you
know maybe around the like the water
cooler but you know what I mean like but
I feel like part of my appeal was the
fact that and it's actually interesting
because as this year was coming up I was
kind of going over some of my most
popular clips and some of my most
popular content and it's always when
like I was talking [ __ ] to someone or
saying something ridiculous or like just
kind of engaging with someone and I
wasn't I have like the ability to not
make necessarily someone else the butt
of the joke I don't have a problem
laughing at myself for making myself the
butt of the joke but I just want
everyone to laugh and everyone have a
good time and I have a foul mouth so
it's hard to be that nice guy
family-friendly all the time when you
you know like you say I say like oh I
want a model laughter Co but Co doesn't
cuss where his worse where that they're
gonna hear him say is [ __ ] so like he
that's he's not you're not gonna hear an
f-bomb on that channel on my channel I
might say something I mean I have an
emote that pretty much implies you know
do it a helicopter dick move so
it's just one of those things where I
have to be me my family friendly is hard
to do cuz like let's take ninja right
you take like ninja who he's playing pub
G and he's cussing and talking all this
smack and then you take ninja who's
playing fortnight and he you can watch
it with your grandmother and you're not
gonna whatever and that's obviously like
ninja prime not now rent well I mean
that's that's part of the best part of
the game like you're so everyone on
Twitch is either now here's their even
though you're they're your friends and
either you have that they can be your
coworker they can be your friend they
can be they're also your competition at
all points no matter what I we're all
competing I wanted to I went to a couple
of panels to pass east and someone
actually said that this is a very large
partner streamer which I'm gonna leave
their name out of it he said that when
he was streaming in he was single he
said what his objective for his life was
he wanted to go start streaming at X
time and end the next time and if you
noticed one of the bigger streamers
started an hour before him he started an
hour before them and then ended an hour
after them and he kept lapping them and
his streams ended up turning into 1920
our streams a day because he just wanted
to encompass his time in that game as
much as he possibly could not because I
asked you a question
what what's that person's health like
well that's the difference the the panel
I was at was talking about work and life
balance so things have changed for him
now but when he was back then it was an
intense type of situation whereas now it
is it's not the case but um you used to
be able to uniquely grow that's what my
channel is an organically grown channel
on twitch with twitch no YouTube no none
of that and other stuff coming in no
viewers from Instagram no nothing I can
see my traffic I can see where it comes
from
it's
it was all twitch all the time people
just found me and I did the same exact
thing sexy Hexy chappie yeah that's all
playing in Division one and I would
literally I would literally sit until
wait until they were all ending their
streets I knew everyone's schedule I
knew exactly what they were showing me
and went exactly when they were ending
and I was on thirty minutes before the
biggest stream ended and I would just
wait for them raining down fall I like
to think of twitch is like a a
rainforest every directories a
rainforest and the biggest the top row
is the top of the canopy and it's gonna
see the most sunlight and occasionally
there's a gap in the canopy and the rain
falls down but not always but if you
know when you sometimes you can you can
time a gap and that doesn't happen
anymore in the larger directories but
there are some more moderate sized
directories where you can still do that
but it doesn't work the same way
I also leverage thing that doesn't work
anymore
I used to stream on console and
PlayStation and Xbox have their own like
before mixer was mixer that you could
kind of just go xbox live and then
stream directly from your xbox we used
to go to twitch and PlayStation doesn't
have their own thing but they have
PlayStation Live but it shows everyone a
PlayStation who's your friend and so I
have like 2,000 friends on face on
PlayStation and so 2,000 people were
seeing when I went live on top of the
people who followed me and so that
doesn't work anymore because so many
people do it and it only works only
people only games they Watchers like
fortnight and fortnight and Call of Duty
so it might kind of work but you really
have to like do a 12 hour shift but yeah
that was another thing that helps it's
really it's really hard to do that
anymore I don't think it's possible to
get partner doing that right do you do
you feel like you've you've accomplished
or you will or I should say you are
accomplishing your goals what's your
take what you want to do I'm sorry
whenever you're gonna say not even close
yeah or anything like now if I was gonna
say if I quit today and did I leave it
all on the table absolutely not
I've been learning too much I've been
reading too many books I've been working
behind the scenes to like change shift
I've like
I'm working on a complete rebranding
overhaul of my everything so yeah do you
feel it do you feel like because you've
noticed how things have been going and
you're you're like me we both got
screwed with division two with the
opportunity I put all of my eggs in a
basket I tied my hitched my horse to the
cart to the Division one and then to the
Division two
if the Division one died I had an
opportunity to leave and go and play pub
geo and pub G partners I had those
opportunities I've met those people
chappy and solid they both went to pub G
and they stuck with it I personally
didn't have this like they had been
streaming for a minute chap when I
started and I met chappy he had been
streaming for three years before me
someone had been streaming for two years
before me and before that he was a mod a
moderator for sexy Hexy and so these
dudes like they're telling me they're
like no dude you need to come with us
right now and I was just like I'm scared
I am sitting at top of the director
every time I play the division I don't
want to risk losing that but I didn't
know what was gonna happen and they did
I had to learn it it was an opportunity
did it suck yes did I like take a hit I
took a big hit did the division - not
being all it was cracked up to be and
you know failing and drowning in its own
hype hit me it absolutely did but it's
not a bad thing it's a learning
opportunity and like fail your way to
victory so it is what it is yeah no I'm
not you know I'm not disagreeing with
you it definitely definitely is
something and that's that's why I've
kind of I feel like you have to have a
plan and you need when you when you're
playing goes south real quick you have
to get out you have to start working and
you have to go okay this didn't work
right so what are we gonna do we got to
do it here all right this isn't work
right we're gonna have to go here like
you're gonna have to kind of twist and
turn it and you know serpentine if you
will to get to the way you're you've
been going I'm gonna talk the way to
make man yes exactly exactly how you got
to those extracts so um how did your
family feel like when you said hey I'm
gonna be a you know full time streamer
my my circumstances with my family is
not the same as like most
like my family is kind of like the
pillar family and then I'm the oldest
son oldest grandson oldest cousin and
I've also always doesn't the best
financially so yeah now that's a III did
very well was that no yeah I didn't mean
it like that
like I have to be the most responsible
so like in that regard I was like I've
been working since I was 14 years old
you know what I mean like I paid for my
sister my little sister's college
education you know so like I'm I grew up
in a household my mom was disabled so
like there's a lot of there was a lot of
struggles and so I was I had to work I
paid for my own college I paid for my
sister's college my dad was paying for
my mom's medical bills like it was a it
was a grind and a half like and so I'm
just used to grinding so when it comes
to like how it affected my family my
family thinks it's super cool my dad you
know I don't I don't I never asked
anybody for anything when it comes to my
family and like they're just super
supportive and even when I do tell them
what I'm doing like here's my
personality type I mean when I moved out
of my house
my parents found out three weeks later
when they thought I went on a vacation I
just never came early I was just like oh
hey I'm gone and they're like okay I see
you didn't come back because I used to
travel all the time I was trying to fill
my entire passport and I was always gone
and I was always here and I was always
there and I love traveling and then I
just left one day and I was just like oh
I packed a really big I went to the
military surplus store bought it back it
was 68 pounds full of clothes and then I
talked to my parent down and ten days I
found a job and then I found another job
five days later and then like two weeks
after that I found a third job and then
I called my dad I was like so my car for
me and like take care of all this stuff
and I was he's like what I mean it's
like yeah ya know my parents are the
only people in my entire family that
knows sure
I haven't like I'm not a I'm a super
independent person so like it wasn't
like oh let me tell my family and then
whatever it's really an interesting
thing especially when you tell people
especially boomers they're like oh what
do you do I'm like I'm a camp girl
that's the easier explaining and they're
like oh you work and you do you do the
computers and you play the video game
just you keep your clothes on why does
everyone always ask that like yes of
course I keep my clothes on no one wants
to see this well if you if you do see
follow you on Twitter and stuff like
that you do get the occasional workout
video so I'm trying to be more posting
pictures on to it I never post pictures
and twitch is doing a thing where
they're like introducing Fitness into
twitch and so they're having some people
who I've been previously doing workout
content in IRL streams and sounds just
like oh I have I literally when I
started when I started streaming so this
is before I started streaming this was
my day I was in the gym at 5:00 a.m. I
was drive to my office and I'd be there
around 7:00 7:30 and then I would work
all day until like 6 o'clock I would get
out and the rest of my day was watching
either a CO carnage vaad or I was
watching Tim at night or I was watching
like summit or dr. Lupo or like someone
who was grinding and that was literally
one day so I worked in finance I still
have all my licenses and all that stuff
but like I worked in finance I would my
own securities practice and so it wasn't
like I wasn't doing well and so like but
it was like I'm not passionate about
what I'm doing and I kind of hate that
half of my day more than half of my day
is spent talking with like really snobby
people about them being really snobby
and like talking about really depressing
things that no wants to talk about one
of the things that I did was I did
insurances for people I also did like
retirement planning and like rollovers
for IRAs and 401ks and stuff like that
so I
I went from like super serious
three-piece suit every day working six
days a week minimum to this t-shirt and
shorts which never no one ever sees
unless you decide to park or in your
bedroom against dreamers don't have like
700 beauties at the kneecaps that's what
I was taking so when when you started
like doing all this like transition over
you'd say did you like hard cut you're
like done doing this gonna end up you
know doing that say I don't know how to
say this so without it sounding bad I
was just like so here's what happened I
waited until so first of all I was
really stressed out I was just like I
was getting up in the morning and I'm
just like I don't know no it wasn't even
it was the person I was becoming okay I
was literally like uh so you know how
like you'll watch and I actually haven't
seen this movie which is kind of funny
but you know how like they always make
reference to a wolf on Wall Street and
it was just a bunch of guys scoops and
they're partying they're doing drugs in
there like that's my that was my life
and I wasn't I've never done drugs my
whole life ever but I definitely could
drink anyone under the table I would
always drink and we would always like
have these huge functions we're all like
doing well for ourselves but it was a
douchebag fest we were all into specks
and it was like who could be the biggest
douche it was a type personalities who's
gonna be the best who's gonna like out
make this much money and someone else's
whatever and what we were all competing
for doctors and attorneys and like all
this stuff
it was just nuts and I mean granted it's
like that's the life and that's fine and
I don't have a problem with it but like
I'm just so much more passionate about
this that the transition wasn't hard for
me at all
and I what I said to myself was I didn't
sell my book of business I actually held
on to it for a while and I gave myself
exactly nine months and then I was like
I'm just gonna try this and my dad was
like I like he would come down
it because you know he lives in Boston
he was retired you probably noticed not
everyone knows but my dad's been police
officer in Boston for 30-some odd years
besides retiring and he'd come visit me
and I'd have him up here and he you know
he would be like Oh every night you're
like watching these guys who are just
like sitting playing video games and
you're like playing video games and
you're watching them play video games
just like if you're really that
passionate about why don't you try it it
was just a good opportunity and so like
I said like I'm a very independent
person but I've had do you have the
support of my my friends and my family's
here do you know about it and it was
just like an easy decision I gave myself
exactly nine months and I got partnered
in eight so and I was there I was
actually there I think a couple of weeks
after you have partnered yeah there's a
nice nice little reprieve on top of
getting ETF which not to be yeah ETF for
the division and sent to Red Storm
studios it was my first time meeting
devs and whole bunch of staff names in
the credits of the game it's very cool
experience because you figured out and
we had a bug out the hunters man that's
why yes and soon you bugged out the
hunters and survival and you're able to
take him out of the pistol well everyone
else was like getting owned and in
fairness I got so yes I often I would
cheese the hunters for the pistol run so
I could go as fast as possible but I've
also killed the hunters with just a
straight-up fight a while freezing cold
in all of my basic gear I've done both
but I the other ones just safer yes no
the most popular clip of me on the
Internet is getting absolutely hammered
by a hunter who didn't like my cheese
and he jumps over the railing just like
what you were screaming at the top here
long so that was funny I never seen know
what they have never done that there he
I was like it was something new yeah
you're joking but I want to ETF they're
like oh yeah we got something for you
thanks guys appreciate it oh boy did you
did you have any questions well because
I'm just gonna sit here Yammer in the
whole time no I mean I feel like you
know him a little better so I'm kind of
just almost listening like a listener
what about you MJ did you everyone has
questions about streaming or just
general questions I got a list of them
so I just wanted to make sure that every
day I had some that said like take take
with a grain of salt before yeah I will
totally answer your question brother but
I'll say take with a grain of salt my my
success I've been like in hills and
valleys hills and valleys like I've
learned and I know what I need to do I
just like having I'm not a groove right
now like my highest viewing on my own
was just a thousand viewers so take that
from someone who's not never pulled
thousand like more than a thousand
viewers by themselves I've only ever
just pulled exactly 995 Ewers by myself
no host so Oh actually that's not true
one time I had 10,000 but that didn't
that was a weird situation that was
warframe and that was a hot drop and
they were just like sitting in my stream
to like get drops they weren't really
watching but yeah otherwise actual
people talking my success has never gone
past that so not attendance at man but I
haven't learned and studied these people
an interesting side now if you're
looking for someone to study and that
hasn't really said what he's been doing
but he does interesting things seems
very transparent dr. Luke Bo Ben is a
really good guy to watch she's very
smart
Ben go ahead I lent you a question every
day go for a brother what do you think
about tick tock I love tic tacs on
personality for it I could post on there
but I like I said my humor is probably
more leaning towards dark so like I
would just have to post Mike's Instagram
same same content you know what I mean
like I could post like playing forward I
can place that content but my humor and
the stuff that I think's funny is a
little bit more dark bean you should do
tick tock oh yeah yes everyone's gonna
want to see me with doing save time well
your guinea pigs yeah oh yes guinea pigs
animals they're super do you feel
oh I'll to get all to get on that
that's what I end up doing on my
Instagram like every single time on my
Twitter like yeah half of my Instagram
and Twitter is video game stuff and
guinea pigs so I would argue that
translating into views Instagram
you tube or way more important but
tick-tock is a good place so here's the
thing about tick-tock right it's like
you're gonna get views from tick-tock
you're not gonna get and this I don't
mean to make it about money but if
you're trying to make a living streaming
there's a difference between why
people's dream if some people I love
when someone's streaming because they're
passionate about streaming and they
happen to be successful I also love when
someone streams because they enjoy
streaming they enjoy talking to people
and they just want to play the video
game so they don't give a [ __ ] because
they make enough money at their job and
they're just doing it cuz they're having
fun I also love that no it's not it
doesn't have to be about competing about
how it makes more money when you go to a
partner party that's all it that's all
it comes down to a lot of people want to
know what your few count says they won't
have subs you got like it becomes like a
dick measuring contest in this kind of
shitty because it takes the spirit out
of like hey we're supposed to be a
community but in reality they're just
want to know who's making the most money
and trying to become friends with the
person who's got more viewers and more
pull than them but it's not like that
for everyone I think on a certain level
once you're like comfortable you don't
think that way but when you're hungry
you're hungry I can respect that is
everyone's got to eat you know I mean I
suppose everybody knows it's for me yeah
now she talks great it's gonna translate
into views but you got to keep in mind
too like a lot of times when like you
want to grow on platforms that generate
revenue because revenue is a resource
money is just a resource for you to
reinvest into your stream if you're
trying to grow your channel you want to
be able I'm not saying Oh make money so
you can have more money I'm saying oh
make money so you can pay another person
to help you create your content so you
can pay an editor you can pay someone to
watch your stream all day for eight
hours a day while you're streaming and
cut your videos while you're streaming
and put your videos on Instagram put
your videos on Twitter put your videos
and that ad revenue pays that person
well do you know you know Eric's right
you've heard of him before yeah yeah so
Eric's is actually a really good friend
of ours and like I've had conversations
with him and
[Music]
and the other ends other people remember
and I met him and like the interesting
thing about iris is that you know it
just started his hip excuse me him and
it's grown into this big thing where
Xfinity yeah he's got this team of
people that are working with them and he
has like four or five streamers that are
all producing all this quick really
really really strong content and then
they're just creating videos off of it
and the amount of revenue he's able to
produce from those you know those
YouTube videos he's able to support like
you know his family and their families
with it and and it's pre it's pretty
amazing it's pretty it's pretty cool and
it's pretty nice to see that happen
that's happening yeah if you can do
something like that and pull something
like that then like that is amazing I
think that what Eric's is doing is
pretty phenomenal and it's a rare
occurrence too because the I've seen
like I hate to throw these boys names
not because I like both of these guys
[Music]
like I I was so there's like in if
anyone's a destiny fan you probably know
there's been two guys who streamed
together forever they were together on
stream and then to watch something like
that vert that literally that's the
polar opposite of Eric's right like he's
like his boys and they are together and
they work together and they do well
together and then there's like to you
guys who are working together and do
well together and I think that's like
the scary it's like is it a coin is it a
coin toss or is that like one destined
to happen versus the other it's a scary
thought but you were gonna say something
about me in regards to this well I was
gonna say for for doing like the that
side of the videos and stuff like that
now are you are you you're starting to
venture more into doing the YouTube
stuff now for yourself I've been
teaching myself I'm one of those people
right so it's like I will make a video
and if I don't like it it'll never see
the light of day I'm sad like you know
like people always count your earlier
when a CEO or maybe it wasn't
someone else that was like hey so how's
the stream looking while I'm playing
this game they're like actually better
than some of the guys who play this and
they get a lot more viewers than you I
am like I will literally after I
register I will go and look at my stream
and if I see any blur at anything in
fact I'm sitting there and tweaking for
the next I don't know how many hours I
didn't get really CD with it and I think
I need to take it out of my hands and
let someone else like who I can trust
their creative whatever and be like
please do this so I don't have to look
at it because I'll lose my damn mind
yeah and so in regards to creating the
content I create it and let them edit it
and do their thing mm-hmm well you're
you're very much a perfectionist in that
aspect like in a perfectionist but also
an over-thinker I have a personality
trait
a fun name for it would be probably
analysis paralysis but I'm good at
getting myself out of it mm-hmm yep now
are you uh are you gonna be going into
any like conventions or Athens this
upcoming year are you gonna try to the
was it called gcx
or it was just down in my town in
Florida or you could come up to back I
haven't made any decisions about those
the only ones that I said that I was
gonna go to was destiny con and that's
that's because bunch of people and where
it was around the corner and they were
like can you do a meet up and I was like
sure I can do that
it's not that far I could go there it's
you know but I also have a trip planned
to go to Paris and for my birthday this
year 30 30 30 right I'm gonna be an old
it's all right man that's night you're
young at heart but yeah so gonna go do
that trip and then I'm going my best
friend's getting married so like that's
the only time off that I'm kind of
allowing myself this year and then I'm a
twitchcon I was just talking to matcha
earlier this morning he's gonna go to
twitch God so maybe if he goes to and
will likely cup I know a lot of like I
really love going to church con just
because it's one of the few times a year
that like the people who you like would
like to collaborate with or you
collaborated with or you're played with
or you've met out of like a partner
party or a thing or Ubisoft did a thing
and they brought all these people
together you get to meet them again yeah
and just chill and like shoot the [ __ ]
and have a drink and just like not
beyond and just be tre versus big denty
or being like band versus be doctor
bloopo or or you know Tim versus Tim
actually Tim was the first man of first
partnered streamers ever met yeah the
first the first partner streamer I ever
met was Dan oh - I met him
we were in PAX East and it was pretty
awesome it's pretty cool
- I feel like I knew that name yeah he's
a good guy he's a good guy I'm actually
uh working and talking to him seeing if
we can get him on here because he was
actually on he was on the the main
podcast I should say the other podcast
um a couple a couple of months ago and I
didn't think at all that I was on the
sub podcast when you said that yeah yeah
we're that were the we're the second the
sister podcast I guess you can call it
yeah and we're on the second string
we're in the bench-warming class do you
get a lot of people that are coming in
to your to your chat and be like you
know people call hateful chat I used to
I'm not real big on so like I'm mixed
but like you get like a lot of weird
race stuff when I first started
streaming you know so like that's been a
thing but like I feel like that's just
like stupid like call of duty chat I
don't really take it seriously I
you can't whisper me and what you can't
message me unless I let you like on
anything only thing that's open is like
my butt like you know someone sends you
like a twitch message it's a little bit
more anonymity
I'm just quick to ban someone dude like
I'm really hard to get it's really hard
to get out of my skin dude so like I
don't pay attention to it and I don't
remember you it's interesting you said
that because I just remembered recently
someone came into my chat they were like
oh dude what's up and I got and he was
just like hey like I don't know if you
remember but you and I used to have beef
back in the division like who are you
what's right yeah yeah man we were like
rivals we were like enemies and I was
just like enemies no enemies what do you
mean other way what happened he's I can
I was doing my thing and you were doing
your thing and I was just like all right
brother you like you know what it's all
good what we say is like we're gamers we
game to game and have fun so like if
you're playing a game that requires PvP
that you know what I don't want to hear
anything from you of hate that I just
sniped you from halfway across a map
because that is what this game is we're
playing games have fun and you know what
it happens to me it happens to you
happens to everybody
I'm completely I'm completely honestly
I'm not like so I'm not the biggest like
so like if I was actually angry I'd
probably get quiet right that's me I'm
like if I'm actually getting mad bro I'm
not saying that I didn't say a word like
I didn't flinch I didn't say anything
I'm hot now because I'm not the type of
person it's like if you were saying
something me and my face I'm not saying
anything back to you fam my I might yank
my shirt off but I'm not saying a word
the yeah I'm just I'm like a knuckle
sandwich type guy like I just grew up in
Boston and we handle things by like
fighting and it might be friends
afterwards but I'm gonna have to beat
you up first even if I lose like you're
gonna know how I felt about it but like
so when people talk smack to me on the
internet like I love it dude I love it
have you guys so yeah you were asking me
if I'm like tick tock you ever seen that
tick tock race like you don't like me
yeah dude that's me that's me bro that's
my spirit animal you don't like me yes
please tell me you don't like me say it
out loud so everyone can hear you so I
can go in yes I don't care dude don't
like me I love that tell me that you
don't like I remove that it's just no I
love the competitive [ __ ] talking cuz to
me all it is is like someone starts
running their gums in a video game dude
they're just that passionate about it
they wanted to win that bad and why I
don't want even say like oh it feels
good to be better but it feels good to
like know that they were that serious or
they take it that serious or maybe
they're that good
because you don't know all the time who
you're facing off but if they're that
passionate about their trying that hard
then you're doing something right right
I say the same thing the streamers
should get mad about stream snipers it's
like bro you got stream cyphers you're
doing something right someone's paying
attention to you found you all right
there welcome to the meat grinder
occupational hazard
occupational hazard exactly do you
[Music]
question for you do you find yourself on
the competitive side because did you do
any competitive online games did you do
swish rebels or no I did I
I didn't decline and it he got cancelled
because there wasn't enough traction in
the division community like one they did
one and it didn't go off and I wasn't a
part of that one cuz I think it was EU
mostly and it was like weird and then
they had an American one and it was like
me I was in a solid was in it Drew's in
it couple other people and they just
cancelled it like randomly and then
there's been other ones so there was
like a code red one for Call of Duty
black out but before I started streaming
I had never played a first-person
shooter I had never really played
competitive I played like World of
Warcraft for ever and then I played RPGs
like I would play like final fantasy
dragon age Borderlands to shoot him if I
was shooting anything it was because it
was like Borderlands or like playing its
side I played like EverQuest I played
lots of online I've been gaming since I
was like very very young and the games
that caught my attention were really
heavily story based games so like
multiple runs through Mass Effect some
of my favorite all I would say obviously
all of my favorite games are all RPG
games until I started streaming i played
the division because i thought it was
gonna be an RPG game otherwise I
probably wouldn't have I you know I play
destiny and even I play destiny for a
while even about the destiny like
limited edition PlayStation got the
whole nine again going back to this part
of me like wanting to have all the
systems and stuff but I just didn't like
ice I found Elder Scrolls online and
started playing mad like a Witcher
series I mean
like that's me only this actually was
gonna say like you you just started
playing The Witcher series was that you
is this your first time doing a full
playthrough or is it you just kind of
picked it up for a little better I
played The Witcher 2 I didn't play the
Richer once I didn't know the story so
and I watched the Netflix series that
was just like what's going on here then
when I played to I was kind of jumping
into the you know I just kind of jumped
in the deep end kind of I felt like and
I had no context of anything about girl
but I was about us and then I played
three but it was like I was like thirty
hours in and then Elder Scrolls online
was playing I wanted to be like we're
walking an elf in a vampire yeah I
actually had a really stupid take
character I think it was like a night
elf but I was like whatever that fire
tank classes so it's like oh I'm weak to
fire but I use fire and I was a vampire
so I was double weak to fire and then
but I was just like really just playing
and hard I wanted to give myself as many
handicaps as possible well not
handicapped so I guess yeah and I was
just playing and being super competitive
with it so that kind of competitiveness
I used to be competitive world of
warcraft pvp i competed and stuff like
that but i never competed in
first-person shooters and i never played
a my i would honestly say that aside
from planetside or Borderlands like
playing a game even like the division
that was the closest experience that I
had and then playing the division that
was like I played on console and then I
played on ps4 than Xbox but then when I
switched a PC that was a whole new
learning experience and even still you
know like I've got like a custom
keyboard and like you know super
lightweight miles tune all that stuff
now but before I was using a Razer Naga
and I like a Logitech g8 keeps big Hoss
ass keyboard with a million buttons
competing and like having the skill set
that I have now before I start streaming
I didn't have it I built it over time
interesting yeah so before before we
start
doing our exits here MJ do you have you
got any more questions for denty or do
you need a moment to think of what we
can break right he asked me what I
thought about it
you cut out there but I think you asked
me what I thought about Ghost Recon yeah
I played it right I play all these tough
games they they give it to you it's like
it's part of the package deals dark it's
not a player thing yeah so I I like I
think so here's the thing right like I
was really hyped for wildlands and I I
got bored like yeah I played it for 14
hours straight and then I was just once
happy everything and then like I tried
to play it for a couple more days and it
was like it was the most boring thing in
the world I couldn't I could not and I
didn't want to say anything negative
because it would be soft had been
showing me so much love and I just
didn't want to say anything negative but
it just wasn't a very good game it
wasn't engaging and they had no replay
value and it's got so bored and story
wasn't very interesting and so I was
kind of like looking at the next one
I Ghost Recon is like it I mean was it
breakpoint as like a like I don't know
bro if you're like wildlands again I'm
not gonna we're gonna have a bad time
but I thought breakpoint was actually a
really good step in the right direction
I do you like that who be soft has an
aesthetic so like depending on what kind
of game they're playing you know it's an
ubisoft game like when you look at the
division you're like oh let's see be
soft when you look at siege that OOP
that's Ubisoft form you look at wild
lands or break point or whatever look at
that's that's Ubisoft so I kind of like
how they're going in the right direction
I just think that they're just not I
feel like everything that they're doing
is just a half-measure and it's like I
don't know if they're like not going all
the way or they need to put one foot on
the shore or if it's because they're
using the terminology Tom Clancy the
name Tom Clancy that they can't go
all-out
but they've had so many opportunities to
do something like I don't know if
everyone hears a familiar with this game
from tarkov
escape from tarkov could have literally
been usurped by so many other companies
they just didn't see it coming
I've been literally I literally have
clips of myself saying this I've been
saying this for two years to the devs in
their faces in person at PAX at ETF at
wherever I see them listen guys you're
sleeping on this game that's gonna blow
up and it's slow it's slow right now and
they've got like 12 devs and they're in
Russia and they're you guys thinking
this game's like whatever and they're
gonna get tired of the cutesy
fortnight's stuff and they're gonna want
something gritty and that's gonna be
that game and here we are yeah well let
me just say I didn't actually answer
MJ's question I thought the gaming of a
step in the right direction
but it just wasn't enough it wasn't
enough for me personally I was on the
fence about buying it and I decided to
not buy it and I saw what everyone did
and they were just like this is exactly
like wildlands and I was a huge fan of
my Alliance so I was like not buying it
so I agree with I grew you know with
what you were saying I knew I saw and I
saw it fall flat and I was like this
isn't my cup of tea but take a step back
what you saying him at the gas room
escape from tarkov this is actually the
original developers it was a developed
originally by two guys and they were
there they are still really good friends
hmm and the the the main development
team that grew and they started building
at the main part of the game one group
of them want to go towards escape from
tarkov
and another one wanted to go towards
very much like a cod type way of playing
it and I can't think would that game is
called off the top of my head but um
they ended up splitting the development
team they got a divorce it was amicable
and they went away went their separate
ways there's still you know friends and
everything but there's some more
visitation rights yeah exactly have
visitation rights on the computer once
once a week but yeah so they ended up
splitting up
they ended up the the one game ended up
kind of falling flat on its face because
it is literally a clone to call of duty
and that whole entire Call of Duty realm
if you will at future and sneak game
no I can't think of what it's called it
wasn't it wasn't futuristic but it kind
of just it kind of has fallen flat and
it's still in that early access just
like escape from tarkov is but the
escape from tarkov guys are just they're
killing it and so and it's very
impressive
yes it's uh it's an ultra core survival
game exactly it's way more than hardcore
it is ultra core and I me personally I
like the challenge that's why that's
where I'm at that's why but L do you do
you have any questions for Tempe that
you could think of I did I said that
last one I went to which was last year I
went to pax Ubisoft sent me two packs
and the hotel room I was staying in I
got like a something bit me bit my face
like a bed bug or something with my face
I had a severe allergic reaction so I
haven't been anything since just because
the doctor said it was gonna take eight
months for the venom to get out of my
system so I just kind of missed
everything and I just felt like [ __ ] it
was a weird situation so I've kind of
been like chilling on doing events but
I'm like I said I'm gonna go to Guardian
cons as long as it doesn't interfere
with my trip and then I will do
twitchcon if you know they send me
anywhere for anything that would be
awesome but those are the ones who and I
have planned for right now it was
knowledge the one that asked you to meet
him out there for gcx cuz it was nerf
actually I've actually met now I'm at
knowledge before he I met him at
Guardian con 2 years ago yeah cuz I'm
one of one of the other podcasts from
the team here is the last word and
mantis and
or kognito those two guys and they go
down there and do a lot of press right
from the floor and talk to a lot of
those guys it's it looks really really
nice and it's actually one of the
there's a couple of conventions I really
really want to go to and that is one of
them I wanted to I want to make it to
eat I want to try to make it to e3 I
really want to make it to the Guardian
Khan and PAX East I always go to because
it's in my hometown it's just a train
ride away so it's going to be it's going
to be interesting too to do that so I'm
sorry because ya know those are the only
ones I plan to go to but usually so like
here's the here's the thing he'll and
protip I don't know if you're streaming
actively or trying to compete fun fact
about when someone you know who might be
like part of your rain forest you know
they might be top of your canopy if
they're going somewhere that's a good
time to be streaming I actually learned
that from Kay goth he there was one year
and he was just like if you go to
twitchcon this year you're gonna regret
it and I was like what and he's like
yeah like I was going I already like
bought everything but it was like a good
time to be in the warframe directory and
he knew beforehand that it was a good
time to be in the warfare directory and
that was when like you know I mean at
the time I maybe had like around 300
subs and then like someone who is like
kind of coming up it were like
neck-and-neck with me at the time would
be like macho he was in the same
directory and he got in the warframe
directory and he ended up like going
from less sub Samee to double my subs
and like the three days I was galavant
and so it's an interesting thing
sometimes when you know it's not super
important and I love macho that's the
bronze literally talking to him this
morning but when you miss an opportunity
it's like I got to hang out with my
friends I got to like network with devs
and I you know like you said L I believe
that you're like familiar
a lot of Microsoft people and so like I
think that year I got to meet like Annie
lanique and a bunch of people you know
what I mean like I got to like be around
people it was a really great time but
they know my face and that's great maybe
some stuff came from it maybe some stuff
didn't come from it but like I could
that was that was like a wave it when
sometimes when you have momentum that's
all it takes
it's for like all of a sudden you've got
this momentum and then someone else who
like might be another league and head of
you notices you and then you guys link
up and then the thing happens another
thing happens nothing happens and that's
like this story of dr. Lupo so he went
from like I used to watch him when he
had like oh like 300 viewers I think
something that if I remember correctly
what he used to do was he would he would
play with a mouse and keyboard on
console and it triggered the [ __ ] out of
people and it was but it was like
clickbait almost right like people would
watch that and so he kind of was in the
the King Italian directory he links up a
king Italian and then it was one thing
after another like who you know he gets
her up shoulder she got to move he got
to do this yes so there's like there's
the networking aspect of it that's
important and then there's being in the
right place at the right time running
into like playing pub key when people
are doing the pub key partner thing and
like running into summit and then
killing summit and then him doing the
famous clip it's like Lupo al Lupo I
know that guy and then playing with
ninja and then his friendship with came
with ninja and then going all round and
then being friends like being best
friends with ninja when ninja blows up
and then ninja pretty much taking his
crew with him like is it's just like
yeah you're kind of always like gauging
it when you're competitively trying to
make a living doing this and you want to
be the most successful and you want to
reach the most biggest audience you want
to touch everyone and you want them to
be a part of your community and you want
to be a part of other people's
communities too they're always kind of
like weighing your options and what's
like a good idea to like miss or go to
an event no no that's that's that's what
you're saying is kind of what I've
always said I've kind of felt like you
have to networking is important and also
being in the right place at the right
time and it's like being struck by
lightning it's
all like circumstance it's all like one
thing will will hinge on another which
will hinge on another and you won't know
until it happens well it's all it's all
like sometimes you make your own look
like let's take like Tim the tap man
right like it I'm I'm probably telling
guys something you already know but like
Tim the tap man will attribute his
success with his channel to the momentum
he got from one time making a video for
sodapoppin and that's actually how I
found twitch was sodapoppin he I was
playing World of Warcraft and I was
doing with my duo partner and we're in
arena and there's drew it came in and he
won v2 to us and he absolutely [ __ ] on
us both and I just looked at google his
name cuz I was like this guy's doing
something I didn't know he could cheat
World of Warcraft what is he doing and
then I was just like oh he's just a god
he's like an actual god and he that's
how I found twitch dude justin.tv I
think so well this has been a fantastic
conversation I had had a great time
talking to you and to like learn you
know so I said the pleasure was all mine
thank you thank you thank you very much
for coming you know so why don't you
tell everybody where they can where they
can find you I had to instill my dream
is dead td3 and seven why everyone just
calls me d3 or dead oh it doesn't really
matter you can find me on Twitter ever
all my soldiers are d3 n7 why the 3 is
an E the 7 is a t /d 3 n7 y on Twitch
come hang out I just shoot the [ __ ] it's
a very like bro-down chill guy girl it's
very like safe place I don't let anybody
bully anybody but me so yeah it's a good
place to chill and right now we're
playing escape from tarkov I play for a
night escape from tarkov
destiny and the division looking for
something to sink my teeth into it might
be
a from talked on if I get good if I
don't get good and it's gonna be fans
only for a little bit change Magic Mike
I know how that man's career started me
on snapchat reaching 430,000 snaps he's
a crazy man with that snapchat so how
long do I have to be sub to get to your
bubble bath only snapchat fans only
snapchat just asking for a friend
[Music]
[Laughter]
I'm sorry so what where can we work will
we find you I thought that's what you
can find me on mixer weekdays money or
actually Tuesday through Friday about 7
p.m. to 9 p.m. on mixer a boogie oh 208
and then I'm on Twitter always nobody Oh
too late to make it easy for everyone
can I ask you a question I didn't know
you streamed on make serious house
what's that like what's the vibe I check
I like it I mean I've been on mixer
since it was beam and I just you know
yeah I'm one of those people like you
said I'm mainly doing it just to have
fun you know I mean when I make
accomplishments it's nice like I just
got a dozen followers so that's nice but
you know I'm not I don't know I make
enough money so I'm not trying to like
Rome okay
I I you know I have upward mobility in
my own career so it's it's literally
everyone's doing it for different
reasons right but I'm just curious what
it's like on mixer
you know jack [ __ ] about mixer but I
think it's interesting I like the idea
that other companies are making twitch
sweat everybody has to do better to keep
you know brand loyalty but what's gonna
say
you starting to see a lot of people move
over but I feel like mixer tries to do a
little bit more to keep their people
around I thought it was surprising when
they got a ninja and everybody else but
I think they needed those people to kind
of boost their platform they're just
huge names you know so well yeah I mean
like they did inverse inverse for all so
I know you guys stream would switch and
switch has their affiliate program guess
what I get to do inverts for all and I
have to be constricted by you can't
stream anywhere else type of thing oh
yeah is that I don't think that's for
affiliates is it so affiliates we can't
stream in both locations at the same
time so I can't stream on any other
platform other than Twitter at that time
but I can end up like stream on Twitch
and I thought I'd say I'm done at 5
o'clock I finished and then at 501 I can
start upon mixer and I can stream on
mixer so I can't information content in
two locations at once it is only for
twitch at that time to say it's very
similar to YouTube like if I had my own
personal YouTube channel and I was
gaming on Twitch I cannot stream to
youtube at the same time so it's just
it's very much a restricted thing where
it's mixer you could pretty much do
whatever you want at any time there's no
restrictions
I mean mixer is open because mixer is
the underdog right now like YouTube and
twitch are like these are mine I have
mine already you
go find your own so basically so yeah
yeah no I totally agree there that's
cool but I like that like I said I like
that and mixer I don't I wouldn't count
mixer as the as the underdog mixer just
hasn't like caught their stride yet they
have the potential to like really take a
dump
odd like let's say that they gave
something to Xbox people like just
console gamers incentive I think that
that would make such a huge difference
imagine if you had some kind of
incentive to stream on their platform
right now let's say you're like let's be
real let's be real for two seconds if
you're an affiliate there's a chance
you're paying twitch to be an affiliate
there's a chance if you're if your
channel is not getting subs if your
channels not whatever there's a chance
that that is happening right cuz I I
don't know I the affiliate program when
I got partnered wasn't a thing I didn't
get to be an affiliate first I don't
know what the the rules are but I do
know that if you want the option to get
subs and emotes and all stuff there's a
chance that if your channel doesn't have
a certain number or a certain thing you
could be affiliate and then actually be
like kind of paying
twitch no it's it's we we actually have
similar breakdowns as partners to the
partners like we if you want we could we
could talk actual specifics later but
yeah the the breakdown is actually very
similar so I mean you can do question
then because this is my obsession if I'm
wrong I can be wrong but like so mine or
someone told me that let's say you get
affiliate but then you have no subs for
an X amount of time you have to almost
like pay like a dues fee for not having
a certain thing so not is that the case
no that's not okay well yeah I just
wrong yeah yeah yeah because the
affiliate program works you can be part
of the affiliate program but you can be
you would have to just state you do not
want direct deposit direct deposit is
what causes a fee so you can it's in the
fine print if you actually a lot of
people don't read those documents
they're just like oh I'm gonna get
affiliate I'm just gonna
I heard them snake in hand but yeah
that's nice yeah that's real yeah yeah
so if you if you have direct deposit and
you say yes is the direct deposit
portion of it then yes you will get a
fee but it's technically not coming from
twitch it's technically coming from the
bank so the bank is hitting twitch
because they're you're forcing direct
deposit on something that has nothing on
it and then that donation yeah and then
then twitch will back hate you that's
not that's how that works
I'll actually do like the affiliate
program but I didn't know that makes
your head one two does does YouTube have
one too whether they have like like oh
yeah well YouTube doesn't exactly have
one you just have to hit a thousand subs
and your YouTube page and then it's a
neat little so much in and then they
allow you to monetize your videos and I
don't know because that's what we hit
yeah because I guess we got our
monetization options once we hit a
thousand subscribers oh yeah also
youtube.com forward slash D 3 and 7 Y
also G discord gg4 slash D 3 and 7 y I
forgot about this that's my first time
being in a podcast I'm gonna be honest I
have a TV real bad so like I can't I
don't with the podcast unless I'm doing
something else which is I usually listen
to like meditation stuff it's like you
are calm you did not have a DD it's okay
that you're trying to pay attention look
a plastic bag we have a couple of
podcast members that I know they can't
they can't sit on a podcast and not do
anything either but I know that they'll
like I'm not talking about us
specifically I'm talking about the other
podcast the one person is always playing
some type of game or Pokemon or
something while he's while they're doing
the other put the iron Lords podcast
itself
so can you act so anyway yeah I'll call
him out on that so anyhow did you have
any other questions then t44 elbow okay
check check
check what no I think we're good okay
all right and myself I am snailed OS and
a ly do you can check me out on Twitch
from Monday to Friday 7:00 to 10:00 if I
am not there I am here on Mondays and
you know I'm on Twitter
I am in our discord I'm in all that fun
stuff if you're if you're looking for
for myself I'd like to thank everybody
else are hanging out this evening I
really appreciate the chat the chat was
uh was pretty intense greatly
appreciated Thank You MJ for for you
know chit-chatting with everybody well
while we got to speak to den T on the
episode it's gonna be coming up on
Wednesday mornings you'll have it up
before for anyone else I usually have it
set so it goes off at like around five
o'clock so you can get it on on all of
your different platforms that you're
looking at for Spotify YouTube all that
fun stuff if you guys end up wanting to
have questions for any of our guests you
can email us at a roundtable stream team
at gmail.com our our twitter is table
stream if you would like to see our
updates and who's our guests and things
like that and go ahead and go there I
have a couple of people were looking to
finalize in addition to that we're gonna
be having the writers from Lords of Gama
gaming over I can't talk today Lords
gaming that we're actually having our
writers come on because we wanted to
give you guys a little bit of an insight
from our from a writer's perspective on
you know what wouldn't what needs to be
working on a website what it means to be
working on the you know our our website
the and other types of platforms and you
know what makes them passion for making
them want to do those things that's
going to be happening between now and
the the end of February so we're gonna
be having those guys on once again the
iron Lords podcast is on on Sundays they
are back on to non-sporting time in
other words they are gonna be starting
at 1:00 p.m. Eastern Standard Time here
on the YouTube page so by all means if
you are here you found us please hit
that subscribe button so you can go
check them out or us
on Monday evenings thank you again
everybody for everything oh I totally
forgot to ask dental my final question
my quick quick final question for you
bud can I ask your question before you
ask your question sure
cuz I've been calling you snellie since
the jump fam and you just said your name
was now no nobody could ever pronounce
it I never I never tell people it's
right or wrong oh my god come on I've
got snail dough in the veins now I don't
know how to smell what is it I get food
smelly smelly or they'll just call me by
my real first name which is Pete so it
doesn't matter to me buts now those the
correct pronunciation so so what if you
could live in one video game world or
environment what would it be
would you love Oh Star Wars nice to the
owner public good old time friend yeah
yeah yeah this is I don't even care even
after microtransaction it's like I loved
that game first MMO that had full-on
voice acting decisions that actually
changed the game C&C gameplay is for me
and an MMO environment where you can't
go back you literally have to reroll an
entire new character to go back
beautiful Star Wars landscape I'm about
it give me force powers yeah eat dab
thank you very much 10t greatly
appreciate your timer thank you so much
and remember everybody dream big and
keep gaming and we'll see everybody next
week I have a couple of people in though
in the wings that are looking to come on
and just trying to finalize those times
keep an eye on Twitter and you guys will
see whoo all right what's up